[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition and this is
one of my favorite lectures where we
talk about least squares regression and
the pseudo inverse so this is an
extremely useful application of the
singular value decomposition is in
solving linear systems of equations ax
equals B so we are very very used to
thinking about the world in terms of
this linear system of equations ax equal
to B lots and lots of physical problems
can be written this way so this is our
famous linear system of equations and
generally we're going to have a is a
matrix that's known B is a vector that's
known and we're gonna be solving for x
which is our unknown our unknown
quantity now you've you've been solving
equations like this for a long time ax
equals to B but the vast majority of
linear algebra classes and textbooks
spend almost all of their time thinking
about the case where a is a square and
invertible matrix so if a is a square
matrix then you have exactly as many
knowns as unknowns and if a is
invertible
meaning its determinant is nonzero then
you can compute the inverse of a
multiplied it by B and that's what x
equals x equals a inverse times B that
would be the solution in this linear
system of equations now that's useful
but the singular value decomposition
allows us to massively massively
generalize this for non square a
matrices so SVD allows us to generalize
the solution of this to non square a
matrices and this is huge
this opens up a much much larger class
of linear systems especially linear
systems that arise in data analysis and
data modelling for example in linear
least-squares regression
okay so I'm really excited to tell you
about this and I think what I want to do
to start is to walk you through a few of
the different things that can happen for
non-square a matrices okay so there are
kind of two canonical cases of non
square a matrices that I want to walk
you through one is the so called
underdetermined under-determined system
of equations and in this underdetermined
case generally we have n less than m and
so we have what I call a short fat
matrix so it's a short fat a matrix so
it's kind of a squat a matrix like this
and then what we would have is at all X
vector times that a matrix equals a
short B vector okay so this is this is a
X and B okay now in general this system
is called underdetermined because
there's not enough measurements in B to
uniquely determine a single unique
solution X in general there are going to
be infinitely many solutions
X given B okay so there's not just one
solution X there's many many many
solutions X that would be consistent
with this system of equations in general
now this is not always true I can
certainly cook up a really degenerate a
matrix so that this is never true for a
particular be a vector but if I just
randomly generated an a matrix that was
squat and a B vector then chances are
they're going to be infinitely many
solutions X given that vector B because
there are kind of more unknowns than
knowns
okay there's there's more degrees of
freedom and X there's not enough values
in B to uniquely determine all of the
values of X good so that that's one case
the other case we think about a lot is
the overdetermined and so we're going to
think a lot about
kind of under and over determined
systems of equations in this case n is
larger than M and so now we have a tall
skinny let's let's actually write that
out we have a tall skinny matrix a and
we're gonna write that essentially as
this tall skinny a matrix it's going to
multiply a short X and it's gonna result
in a tall B B vector okay now again
there will be degenerate cases there are
some B values where there is a unique
solution of this or even infinitely many
solutions but in general if I just
randomly generated this system of
equations some a matrix and some B
matrix in this over determined case
where there are more equations than
there are unknown values in X then in
general there will be zero solutions of
this that exactly satisfy this equation
so again this is not always true but
there in general will be zero solutions
X for a generic B vector okay and that's
because there are not enough degrees of
freedom in X to fit all of these
equations in general ok there's there's
too many equations it's over determined
again I can cook up examples where this
is not true what the singular value
decomposition is going to allow us to do
though is going to allow us to
approximately invert this a matrix to
compute what's known as the pseudo
inverse and find a best fit X that
either comes as close to solving this as
possible or solve this equation with
let's say the minimum two norm of the
vector X so I'm going to write out
exactly what I mean by that and what
we're going to have let's assume that I
have my matrix a I take a singular value
decomposition so I have you Sigma V
transpose I'm going to assume that this
is an economy SVD and I'm dropping the
hats then what we can define is this a
dagger the pseudo inverse of a called
the more penrose pseudoinverse and I
think I actually want to write it out
explicitly in the following way let's
say we have a X equals B and I'm gonna
write for a you Sigma V transpose x
equals B and now what we're gonna try to
do is we're gonna try to invert each of
these matrices one by one to solve for X
on the left hand side and again that's
one of the nice things about these being
unitary and diagonal matrices is that
it's really easy to invert each of these
matrices one at a time okay
so what I'm gonna do if I want to invert
this I'm just going to write this one
more time u Sigma V transpose x equals
and I'm going to give myself some room
here if I want to invert you I just
multiply by u transpose if I want to
invert Sigma I'm going to multiply by
Sigma inverse and if I want to invert V
transpose I'm going to multiply by V and
so this matrix here is what I'm defining
as a dagger the pseudo inverse that's
equal to V Sigma inverse u transpose and
this is what's known as the more penrose
pseudoinverse because my matrix a is not
square a proper inverse doesn't exist
and this is as close as I'm going to get
to inverting that a matrix and solving
solving for x and so again this cancels
to the identity this cancels to the
identity and this cancels to the
identity and so I'm left with X let's
call it X tilde it's kind of my best
approximation is equal to V Sigma
inverse u transpose B which we're going
to define as a dagger B that's how we
define the pseudo inverse and it's
technically the left pseudo inverse
because a is multiplying X on the left
and I want to invert it on the left if
it was x times a I would invert it on
the right and I get a right pseudo
inverse okay so a pretty simple idea
we're going to use the SVD
a to invert to pseudo-inverse this a and
solve for X and this is somehow the best
X we're going to get for these two
equations linear systems of equations
okay and specifically these X's actually
mean something so in the underdetermined
case in this case here there's
infinitely many solutions
this is the X tilde has the minimum two
norm so the x2 is minimum this is the
let me let me write this a different way
we have essentially the minimum to norm
X such that a X tilde equals B is given
by this solution so of all infinitely
many X tilde is that do in fact satisfy
this this one is the solution that has
the minimum two norm okay so we call
this the minimum the minimum norm
solution and sometimes that can be
useful maybe you know maybe this
corresponds to energy or something and
having the minimum norm is like the
cheapest way of multiplying a by a
vector X to get this the specter B now
in the case where there are no solutions
in this overdetermined case this is
still kind of the best solution we're
going to get what this does is this is
the what's called the least square
solution it minimizes the error between
a X tilde and B this two norm error so
this is called the the least squares
solution so even if there is not an
exact solution to this over determined
system of equations this pseudo inverse
solution X tilde equals a pseudo inverse
B is somehow the solution that minimizes
the error in the fit between ax and B so
even if I can't exactly find an X that a
times x equals B this is going to be the
one
that has the minimum to nor impossible
the least squares solution and this is
the cornerstone of linear least squares
regression we're going to talk a lot
about that in the next few lectures but
I really wanted to just point out that
you have now the power of generalizing
these linear systems of equations to non
square matrices a and we compute instead
of the inverse the pseudo inverse using
the SVD and that solution that you get
when you solve for x has these very nice
optimal properties they're either the
minimum norm solution that satisfies the
system or the least square solution that
satisfies the system okay so we'll talk
more about this in the next few lectures
thank you